hey everyone it's Mike for motf flows
and welcome back to my channel you know
in today's video I'm going be talking
about uh exhaustion in the market and
you know it's exhaustion is one of those
things that for me as an orderflow
Trader it's something that I've always
looked at actually even before um I I
looked at a footprint chart it was
something that I'd always try to
identify in the market based off of
looking at a depth of market right the
the the Dom or the Dome however you want
to pronounce it
and problem was before right if you're
looking at the price ladder right you
really got to be focused in on that
Market's price ladder and watching how
much trades at a price level but with
the footprint chart it makes it a hell
of a lot easier in identifying these
areas um where there is price exhaustion
now before I jump into the video you
know if uh you're serious about learning
order flow make sure to hit the
Subscribe button and turn on the
notification Bell that way you won't
miss any uh new video that I post all
right so let's jump into what exhaustion
is
now exhaustion prints in the orderflow
they offer significant benefits to
Traders right because they provide you
with insights into market dynamics and
can be um very useful in identifying
potential reversals or continuations
okay and let's sort of just jump into
the footprint chart it's easier to
explain it to you by by looking at the
chart so you can see here right every
price level more or less has something
that trades on the bid or the offer
right in the footprint
and why I like using the footprint as
opposed to a price ladder is because a
price ladder you're you're looking at
Traders intentions of what they want to
do in the market whereas on the
footprint you're seeing actual trades
that took place right and and to me
personally I just find it more important
to look at sort of Traders intentions to
the market right because you know
someone either got into a position at
that price or they got out of their
position at that price and you know like
I said you know every price level has um
volume and and really what you're
looking at is with exhaustion prints now
this is where it gets differ this is
where it differs
from a price ladder because a price
ladder people are always looking for the
heavy volume to take place but with
exhaustion prints you're looking
for the Lesser volume to take place and
and what do I mean by that is is look at
this area right here okay um 17 right
I'll just draw these little lines in
here so you know we're trading 17 back
and forth um pretty good you know here's
about 1100 2200 3,000 1,00 200 300 1100
1200 300 500
700 300 then show 18 then it starts
coming off you're coming back up to this
level it trades
six okay that is a sign of exhaustion
right so we're coming back up to a level
where you had been trading um you know
decent volume and and how do I know this
is a level well I can see you got a
couple point of controls at that level
there's some decent volume going through
but what draws my eyes to it is this
small volume at the edge of the bar six
you come off rally back up to that same
level 17 you trade four contracts this
bar trades 7,000 contracts but you like
manag to trade four here right and you
see how this Market is selling off um
you know quite nicely from that area all
the way down right now to 08 you know
I'm showing bonds because um today's
January 9th and I believe it's uh stock
market is closed due to uh the funeral
former president uh
Carter okay but you know that that's
what exhaustion is it's it's traders
that are no longer interested in
transacting at Price just like here
right you see there's one here okay you
know get back to yesterday here look at
this we we rally up from 5 all the way
up to 10 right
11125 all the way up to 11210 I mean we
hit 09 came off came back up 09 someone
traded 10 okay now you know I know the
tricks that Traders play especially if
we're coming back up to testing a High
um you know one of the tricks is I say a
trick but one of the ways to Traders
would always check to see if there's
interest in the market
is buy the new high see if it triggers
any stock or see if it gets other
Traders interested right cuz you know a
lot of Traders look at a simple bar
chart and they're not looking at the
volume so they don't know whether it's
one contract or 100 contracts they their
um you know their
indicators will take that print at the
new high and and calculate the new level
at whatever you know RSI macd whatever I
don't I don't care what you're using but
that's what Traders do is they they sort
of they will go up and Test new highs
Orest new lows and if nobody's coming in
then they just cut it right but as a
footprint Trader if you see something
like that where the market comes up
trades one contract then starts selling
off you know there's no interest up
there right so then you could position
yourself short with what a stop right
around that area I like to put it just
above the exhaustion print right right
up here at
11 and you got this nice move down below
25 you know where you were trading
earlier before that um sharp runup so
you know identifying potential reversals
is one of the main benefits of using
exhaustion prints
now in the old days right when it was
just like Market Delta was you know the
main footprint chart um you know there's
a few others gy Etc out there this was
10 years ago in the early
uh you know 2010 I say 10 but you know
11 12s 13s 201 you know 13 2014 when it
was just basically you know one or two
footprint software out there
um you know you just had basically this
is what it looked like right you didn't
have any of these other tools then then
I met a a programmer that understood
orderflow cuz he had developed his own
footprint chart I said hey can you
highlight to me where these areas of
exhaustion are taking place right and we
just call it single prints now we we
changed the name years ago to exhaustion
prints because it's more accurate and
yeah so we have it in our orderflows
Trader right here so to enable it you
just click on enable now there's two
ways you can draw it before I just used
to
originally way I used to look at it was
like this where it would just highlight
that little area there right on the
footprint right one
one8 now you could set what you want
your exhaustion to be you know for most
markets nine is is good enough but if
you're trading a thinner market like say
m andq or ym you know you'd probably
bring it down to a smaller number five
or three
even but now one of the ways that I like
to always look at things is I like to
draw out the
Zone um until tested I'll show you that
what that looks like here so fixed
change it to until tested
okay and so that it would just draw it
out until it's tested again like this
one was tested here just like here came
back here tested that level came back
here tested that level now there are
some Traders I know that use exhaustion
prints just like this they trade the
pullback to the level and they're
they're very um have very tight stops I
mean you could almost trade it to the
tick I I I don't know if I can
um do that where I would just come back
you know I got an exhaustion print put a
limit in here with a stop one tick below
you know because you're going to get
stopped out um quite you know this would
be a stop out this would be a stop out
by one tick um you know stop out stop
out but again you know if you're only
risking one tick you could have a pretty
decent um you know risk to reward ratio
because you're only risking one tick I'm
not advocating that Traders do it here
it came right back to the the same tick
and but anyway I sort of digress what I
want to talk about
is you know using it in a move right for
continuation okay because like I said
you know normally how I would use it as
a a tool in a reversal right like here
right we have this move up right the
exhaustion print then you came down and
but what I found also is in moves if you
get that exhaustion print in the bar
itself as this Market is moving up it's
also a strong signal right so while it's
it's nice for finding reversals you
could also use it for
continuation okay just as here right
well this is on the Futures closes the
next day already on the reopen all right
you here just sort of went sideways but
here right as what's taking place okay
so here's if you want to take this as
your reversal this is your continuation
signal so if you're short already then
you see this come in this other
exhaustion print coming in um you know
it's a strong there's probably a strong
sign you can see this Market is going
lower volume is going lower point of
control is at the bottom of this bar
right and you know when when Traders are
are looking at
things because it's exhaustion print is
volume dependent right it's it's lack of
volume at the edge of a red bar or
bottom of a green bar and people say
well maybe there was just light volume
okay well look at this bar coming in at
the swing High it traded
9,142 contracts that's solid previous
bar only traded
3,700 previous bars 1,200 previous bars
900 here you got 8,000 here's 5,000 so
you know 9,000 is legitimate so it's not
like it's coming in um you know one
contract on 150 contracts no it's solid
it's it's strong volume there right
here's a move up using exhaustion prints
as
continuation right here's off your
little swing low going
up you know this was
overnight where is it here 6:30 you know
sometimes trading Bonds in the middle of
the night or late evening going into the
midnight time is like watching paint dry
honestly um I'm not sure that's
something I'd want to do you see here
right we hit
this we come down in here hit the swing
High double bottom here then it starts
coming down then you get that nice move
down here exhaustion print exhaustion
print exhaustion print exhaustion print
exhaustion print all on this move
down so you know there's different ways
you could use exhaustion prints and for
me it's a very effective tool in
analyzing the order flow especially when
you get into um you know combining it
with other aspects of order flow okay
such as things like zero prints or thin
prints um you know you could even add in
what do you call it uh imbalances right
there there's a lot of different tools
of order flow that you
[Music]
can combine with exhaustion prints so
you know basically
if with exhaustion prints um you know
look for them after Trends or you know
moves um look for them when Market is
testing uh a a a level right of support
or resistance and again doesn't matter
how you identify support or resistance
if it's coming up to a level that you've
identified as support or resistance
right maybe you're using um a foot uh
not a footprint um maybe you're using a
volume profile right if you're coming
back up to a high volume area right or
the value area high or the value area
low look for that exhaustion prints
right um again you'll look for Extremes
in the market right when the
markets reach new highs or new lows not
just you know swing highs or swing lows
right it it could signal the end of a
move
so you I've made count I'll say
countless videos I've made a bunch of
videos in the past about exhaustion
prints and the reason for that is
because it is a very important part of
orderflow right I mean you know we could
talk about Delta we could talk about
imbalances we could talk about point of
control but when you start looking at
exhaustion prints you're actually
analyzing the volume that's taking place
in the bar and the beauty of it is it's
not something you guys sit here and look
at the footprint you could easily
identify it using the orderflows trader
or if you're not using order with with
your eyes right it to me something
should just jump off the page an
exhaustion print should jump off the
page if you're at a swing high right
this you got this double top here right
going from the day before to the next
day and you see lack of volume that's a
good
signal okay so you know again sometimes
I feel like I'm preaching to the choir
but again don't underestimate the power
of exhaustion prints all right everyone
so again you know if if you've liked
these videos that I'm putting out be
sure to to subscribe to the channel hit
the like button definitely hit that
notification Bell so whenever I post a
new video you'll be uh aware of it all
right everyone I'll catch you guys on
the next video take care